my name is Ben roguegeon online I go buy
the Seattle data guy and to keep intros
short I have checked I think chat gpt4
knows who I am so you can ask chatgpt uh
about me if you don't know who I am
um so yeah I wanted to do a talk based
on basically my last couple maybe almost
almost decade now in the data world and
just things that I've seen and things
that I'd hope to see less of in the next
few years well we'll never get rid of
everything
um you know we'll have Cobalt with us
until you know the uh whatever End of
the Universe
um so I want to take this from kind of
three different points so the kind of
Technology process and people
perspective
um so we'll kind of go through that uh
whole rigmarole through these different
sections
um starting within the first thing uh
which there's a lot of talk I think
about like the zero elt or zero ETL kind
of World
um which I think most of us would
consider more of a zero El world and
I've kind of had two for some reason or
another do a lot of SFTP uh jobs in in
my career uh the very one of the very
first uh jobs I had as a data engineer I
was at a house was at a healthcare
analytics company where we would take 40
or 50 different insurance providers data
sets
um and basically you know they'd all
send it to us via SFTP they'd all have
different data formats you know if you
think CSV is one there's CSV tsv pipe
delimited positional XML Json and
basically have to take all of that and
make that into some form of standardized
format so we could create data analytics
products that we would end up selling
back to companies like Amazon and Boeing
to get them get them an idea about the
health of their population essentially
if their worker population so I had to
spend a ton of time setting up these
jobs making sure they were still working
uh and for some reason that continued
when I went to Facebook I somehow got
deemed the person that was going to do
very Sim similar work and had to work
with a lot of the external and internal
partners and setting around SFTP jobs
and you know while you're doing it I
don't think you think about it you're
like this is just the way the world is
you know I have to like spend a bunch of
times in emails you know setting up
agreements making sure that yes we can
get this data yes this is okay uh from
there you know asking them about the
schema uh them sending over schema file
them sending over a test file uh and
then for one reason another you always
get one out of ten where the test file
never matches the real file and spending
a lot of duplicate time reworking uh
your jobs and then to add to that the
the other thing I'd always felt like I
was spending a ton of time doing uh was
dealing with various ways that companies
would encrypt or you know put some sort
of password protection on these files so
it was just this constant work where it
was like okay so this one they did the
password and encryption this one they
did a password this one they did just
encryption and setting up all these
different scenarios and so that's why
one reason one of the things I'd love to
see less of I think is sftps uh just in
general because we're kind of getting to
this world where there are other options
and that's personally exciting for me uh
the more we can get to that you know I
think we are pushing towards a world
where yeah uh SFTP might might uh
disappear a little bit
um I'm actually working with a few
companies right now where this is kind
of what what they're going for they're
like several organizations where it's
like hey we want to get data from all of
the various kind of schools and
universities and we would like to then
be able to proliferate it out and one
way we could possibly do that rather
than again setting up a hundred SFTP
jobs which would probably take a year
plus of someone's time on all different
sides
um and I imagine millions of dollars
just because that's how it takes
especially in the nonprofit world when
it comes to just people going on
vacation so
I just kind of view and I'm kind of
hoping to see this more and more and I'm
starting to see some companies I had one
company earlier this year who started
building data products uh this way where
they're like hey we're going to build on
Snowflake and now you can just take your
data from Snowflake directly and it
doesn't have to be snowflake I know
there's plenty of other options uh
actually this morning I was talking to a
solution that is looking to you know
make it so whether your data's in data
bricks or snowflake or Azure or whatever
they can share it openly across all of
those various uh kind of formats because
obviously that's currently a restriction
that I imagine most of these larger
organizations don't want to solve
um just for for their own purposes
um so that's that's something I think I
would really like to see more of and and
see well see less of in terms of SFTP
and more of in in this kind of world
where data's a little more open I was
always remembering again back to uh when
I worked at Facebook is that everyone
would have their kind of own namespaces
and if you ever want to like get access
to data and someone else like let's say
ads data as long as there's no security
issues you could just easily go to UI
and be like hey I know this is where
this table is coming from I know what
this table is named I'll find it and
just Port it over uh to to my name space
so I can use it and it will just
automatically be synced so that's
something I'm hoping to see more of I I
imagine people are are planning this I
don't know if you guys are but that's
definitely something I'm really
personally excited about and uh hoping I
can do more to like remove uh any SFTP
job for me it just feels like a lot of
duplicate work so that's one thing that
I'm really excited about I think kind of
reducing in the future
um so from a processes did I hit it
so from a processes standpoint
um I think I like many consultants kind
of have this curse where we get brought
in um often to fix problems so we maybe
have a little more of a bias view on in
terms of what is going on uh so I think
last year 30 of my time was spent on
fixing what I call Key person dependency
issues so that's someone built something
in the past they quit you know they're
not there anymore please come in and and
fix this this problem uh one of the
things that you kind of see throughout
this whole thing is you'll sometimes
come into a solution like last year I
came into someone's solution that had
developed a airflow-like system
themselves but this has clearly been
built over several engineers and several
Architects timelines so you saw Every
Which Way uh that they had developed
each kind of different path and job it
made me think if any of you have read
um the mythical man month uh there's
like a chapter where he talks about how
these Cathedrals
um basically over hundreds of years
despite having you know multiple
Architects and multiple people build it
they had some sort of core uh design and
and you could see it and you wouldn't
have all these weird kind of hodgepodge
designs that changed with the times
um but that's I something I'm not seeing
currently uh usually when I come into
different teams or coming to different
projects it feels like there's various
standards that were kind of put into
place either that was because there was
a lack of standards in the beginning so
they'd never anything to connect to or
you know just everyone kind of set their
own and I think we are going to this
world where that's you know it's clear
where to start
um I I was really excited when I think I
saw like gitlab and a few other
companies had like their standards and
and design processes out there they were
very similar to the ones that our team
at Facebook had so I was like okay you
know we're starting to get to a point
where people can just find the stuff
online you know when I first started it
was just like you kind of guessed you
know maybe you read a book and kind of
tried to implement what you found in a
book but I think there's a lot more of
this information aggregated online
um just as kind of another Point uh you
know like what is what does this lead to
I I just remember one specific project
uh where where like lack of Standards
led to was your kind of classic uh data
swamp I just took this from the data
engineering subreddit so you can
honestly just look this up if you'd like
to take this image
um but yeah since they had never set
standards when I got into essentially
their data Lake
um they never put any sort of folder
structure in place and everything was
literally in a folder called Data uh for
the last like five years and you know
they probably had like 10 or 20 data
sources that they were pulling every day
or two or three times a day and
thousands and thousands of files that I
had no idea what was going on and so
that that to me kind of spoke to like
there being a lack of Standards early on
um that never kind of got fixed
throughout time
uh but again I think this is something
that we can slowly start to fix I think
uh there are tons of options you know
you can just honestly Google uh I like
again gitlab has a has a good like open
uh documentation there where you can
kind of get a good understanding of what
good standards could be and and build
from there like no one's saying you have
to take them you can kind of build your
own
um but I think like having documentation
in terms of like what things should look
like in your company and like making
sure you pass it on through onboarding
through good processes
um then you'll kind of uh avoid a lot of
the problems that I I feel like have
occurred
um over the past probably decade so
that's something I'm excited about I am
seeing more and more people do this I'm
seeing more and more people Implement
things like linters and formatters from
the get-go rather than like having
everyone kind of do whatever they want
and over time things kind of just
decaying
all right so for my final my final point
in terms of things
well this one's less of a things I'd
rather not see but just things that I
think are changing so uh I saw this
I saw this post and maybe that's smaller
than I realized but saw this post from
uh Zach from uh linked or actually this
one I think was on Twitter where he
basically talked about the fact that for
the next few years yes data engineering
might blow up and then it might kind of
dissipate and uh mold into software
engineering
um and and this just kept making me
think how I think for the last few years
uh you know companies have wanted to
live in this in this state right like
the current state is we have software
engineers and data producers on one side
we have data Engineers who kind of tend
to be the bottleneck uh sorry data
scientists uh and then you know data
scientists and analysts on the other
side who really want access to data but
they're usually kind of slowed down
where companies would prefer you know
just to be directly right there
everything's connected
um and I keep thinking about like where
where is this going
um because I have people because if
you've seen my YouTube content a lot of
the a lot of my YouTube content tends to
be intro so I get a lot of people asking
like is data engineering going to be
around found in the next few years you
know it is a good job Choice uh which
the first thought I I kind of have there
is
um welcome to Tech uh I don't know like
you know technology changes like when I
first started I was working on Oracle
and SQL Server then shoved into Hadoop
and now on the cloud so it's like
it it might change but I think the
things I do know
um you know in the last few years I know
that Airbnb at one point tried to get
rid of data engineers and then roughly
had to bring them back a few years later
um just to have someone own the data
sets so I do think a lot of things will
change in terms of maybe how data
Engineers look maybe the work we're
doing is slightly different but I feel
like someone will always end up owning
uh the data sets what they look like
their quality their reliability I think
that's an unavoidable kind of state
um and in most cases most data Engineers
are overworked anyway so maybe we have
better tools uh you know we're no longer
having to write mapreduce jobs that's
great we're maybe now getting to a point
where we're not having to build our own
infrastructure that's great but there's
always something at the end where it's
like someone has to manage what the data
looks like you know what's the actual
reliability of it so it's really hard I
think to get rid of that last little bit
but you know I'm not gonna call it I I'm
no Oracle but I I don't think this is
something we'll see that will disappear
uh in the next five years
honestly that is my talk
[Music]